okay
welcome to another week of uh
science and technology q a for kids and
others
and uh happy to take all kinds of
questions easy ones
hard ones ones you think are easy ones
that will turn out to be really hard
ones that you think are hard which turn
out to be easy
uh different topics about science
technology history of science history of
technology
um future etc
all right let's um
okay so there's a question from jack
here for a
math and science career what is the most
useful subject to study in school
excluding math and
uh what was my favorite non-science
class or subject in school well those
are two different things but
but the number one thing is understand
computation
understand computational language
understand computational thinking
those don't that isn't something that
gets taught
in current quotes math and quote
science it's something and it doesn't
get taught really in current quotes
computer science computer science
is really about these days mostly
not always it's slightly different
things in different places
about kind of the care and feeding of
computers as they are so to speak
um the you know the thing i've obviously
spent a lot of my life doing is building
this whole stack of computational
intelligence this whole
computational language or from language
all these kinds of things
that um uh are a way of getting it to
the point where we can
describe the things that we're
interested in in computational language
and then it's up to the language to
implement those things so we can say
you know if we're studying um something
about
some area of i don't know plant science
or something
uh the you know the the language knows
information about plants it knows how to
compute
things about uh these different
questions that you have and so on
i would say that the the number one the
zero thing probably
to learn about is kind of the
computational method
you know how to think about things
computationally
computational language as a way to take
that computational thinking
and actualize it as a thing that you can
have a computer help you with and so on
so that i would say is the zero thing to
get out of
uh out of learning and it's something
which is still
pretty embryonic in terms of what's
taught in school
um but that's a really important thing
and uh
you know even i've written a little book
about uh
uh you know elementary introduction to
welcome language which
uh you know i think it's a pretty good
book um but the
lots of them there's a mooc version of
it and so on but those that's an example
of a kind of thing that
is uh is it really worth learning
because if you've
if you really understand this kind of
computational method that's made
possible by our computational language
and so on
this is a superpower basically you can
do things and i it's always
fun for me to see because there are
plenty of people who know this stuff
well
now it's always fun for me to see that
they go into these different areas
they're interesting things they take a
class about this thing or that thing
and suddenly they can just sort of uh
do all these amazing things with them
with these tools and that's um because
they understand kind of the
computational method
and they understand computational
language so i would say that's sort of
the zero thing to say about um
uh about what um
what one can um things to learn in
school so to speak
i would say that the um the other thing
is
uh learning to sort of express oneself
um both and that's kind of a story both
in computational language
and in natural language in english or
whatever
language it is um you know learning to
write and write well and explain
yourself well
that's a super useful thing um it's
uh i don't know how similar it is you
know explaining yourself well in
computational language
is uh in some ways similar to explaining
yourself well
in natural language it's all about kind
of organizing your thoughts
to the point where you can communicate
in the case of natural language directly
to other humans
in the case of computational language
both to other humans and to computers
um but that's uh so i would say that
that um
learning to write computational language
on the one hand and natural language
like english on the other hand
these are really worthwhile things i
would say in general
um that just
well knowing about a bunch of different
areas is
just knowing facts about different areas
is super useful like
like i don't know i i guess that i never
thought i learned
much about like history for example when
i was in school but actually it turns
out i i know
sort of enough basic history that when
things come up
i could sort of piece them together and
understand uh sort of how things worked
i mean i i myself happen to have been
pretty interested in history of science
and technology
i'm just working on a little project
right now that involves a bunch of
history uh
in europe around the 1920s and so on and
having some basic knowledge of what
happened in the first world war and
things like that is kind of important
to not get utterly confused about um
uh about um about what went on in the
particular piece of history that i'm
studying and
i think history is a useful thing to
understand to sort of contextualize
what's there today now you know i have
to say when i was in school
um you know my learning of history i
didn't like it all
um i think perhaps because of some
details of
how i sort of went through different
years of schooling i
i think i learned the history of the
1600s i
i went to school in england and you know
in england they teach
you know every country teaches history
differently and you know in england for
example
you know what in the us is called the
american revolution but when i learned
that in england it was always called the
american war of independence
i mean it's just a sort of a different
perspective on the same set of events
but for some reason i learned the
history of the 1600s in england like
three times
and i'm like this is completely boring i
do not care about these dates
i don't care about these battles i don't
care about you know
uh you know um charles the first of a
cromwell english civil war all these
kinds of things i it just
it seems very remote and um even though
you know
some of the events happened in places
near where i lived and so on it's like
okay there's a there was a battle here
you know 350 years ago and now there's a
field
great terrific now what well
of course in the way these things come
around um
in uh i've done a lot on history of
science
and the 1600s was a very important
period in the history of science and one
that i've studied a lot
with people like newton and leibniz and
sort of the beginning of mathematical
science and
all those kinds of things coming in and
so it's kind of i feel a little bit
silly for having been like i'm not
interested in the history of the 1600s
when i was in school um but i think that
just knowing
sort of basic facts about history
geography all these kinds of things
you know knowing basic facts about
things is really useful um
i would say that that being to the point
where you can really calculate things or
do
uh do sort of uh you know i think that's
having
a broad knowledge of lots of facts is
really useful at least i've i've always
found it so
another area that i have to say i didn't
learn when i was in school is things
about philosophy
um and i think that uh uh there's a lot
that's interesting there about kind of
ways to think about things i mean the
fact is that
the kinds of questions plato asked are
still questions we might ask today
it's like i at times had thought you
know why would one want to study
something like aristotle
you know a lot of what aristotle had to
say about sciences is known to be
complete nonsense but
it's actually interesting to look at the
arguments that were made
by people different times in history
because you know what
if you're just sitting and thinking
about these things by yourself not
informed by all those facts of modern
science and so on
you would probably come up with the same
conclusions and it's interesting to
unravel them
and try and see why isn't that the right
conclusion why
you know how to think about those kinds
of things so i think
this i mean a big theme is how to think
about things is a super useful thing to
learn
in education and whether that's
something you can get uh
from learning sort of philosophy i mean
you can get uh i'm sure
you can learn in a very formulaic way
which isn't so useful
but learning it as a way of here's a
question how would you think through
this question
that's a pretty useful thing and it's
true
not only for sort of the philosophy that
directly affect science and technology
but also for things like ethics and so
on
just kind of working through how do you
think through a problem given this
question
that's a a a complicated question how do
you think it through i mean
one feature of philosophy that differs
from something like science
is that kind of anybody at sort of any
stage of life can have opinions about
sort of questions and philosophy
they may be more or less informed
opinions but they can nevertheless have
opinions whereas if you ask somebody you
know something about
um uh you know what do you think
about the schrodinger versus heisenberg
pictures of quantum mechanics
well most people will have nothing to
say about that
until they've learned a whole stack of
actual detailed content
um about about mathematics and physics
and so on
whereas uh a similar question you know a
question about philosophy
everybody can have an opinion you know
given an ethics question should the
self-driving car
do this or do that you can have a whole
discussion about that at sort of any
any level and i think that's useful
because i think learning to think about
stuff
is really worthwhile i mean learning
facts learning to think about stuff
learning to express yourself to humans
into computers these are all really
useful things
i mean i think that uh
you know when i was in school i i
learned various
languages other than english i learned
latin and greek which i thought were
just completely useless at the time
although i found them kind of
fun and i learned french
which i also thought was pretty useless
at the time um
and uh latin and greek are interesting
partly because well latin in particular
because it's a bit of a simpler language
than english and it's a good excuse to
kind of learn structures of languages
and
grammatical structures and things like
that um and that's
that's good and and for me in
practicality i've
you know i i end up having to make up
names for things and i end up trying to
understand things in technical fields
where
the words come from latin and greek so
in fact the knowledge that i have of
those
of those languages is is surprisingly
useful to me even though i thought it
was going to be quite useless
50 years ago when i was learning those
things um
in terms of of other human languages you
know
i think it it my own experience of that
wasn't particularly good i mean i i
can read french and understand french
i'm i'm always too nervous to actually
speak it and whenever i do people can
look at me like
and they start talking to me in english
so it's it's like um
i think french is a particularly
exacting language in terms of people's
uh
willingness to uh to speak in the
language because it's a language that um
but but you know there's a there's a
utility i guess
if you get good enough to be able to
actually understand other languages
it's probably useful i i just haven't
gotten to that point
people say uh i have no evidence for
various claims that people make that you
know learning human languages
is useful for learning computational
languages i don't actually
i don't know if that's true i mean i
know people have studied that question
and say that people who learn computer
languages programming languages a little
bit different from computational
language but learn
programming languages also learn human
language as well
if i'm an example i'm not a good example
i've learned
many programming languages and not many
human languages
but i would say also just in terms of
things to do in school
i mean another thing that i would say is
you know doing projects and answering
questions that you have
where you can go and for example
particularly using
computational methods um you know answer
those questions
being able to go from formulate the
question to do something to answer the
question this is a super useful thing to
do
and a lot of times in school the only
thing you get to do
is uh you know here's a standardized
thing to be told
here's an exercise to do that's been
done a million times before go do this
exercise
and sometimes that's a useful thing to
get practice to get to
to get to a certain level of fluency and
understanding how to do things
but um at least for me it's like
there's so much more mileage from having
something where you thought of the
question yourself
you're kind of motivated to get to the
answer yourself and you have the
experience of both seeing what happens
when you formulate a question
and see what happens when you kind of
get to the answer by all means necessary
so to speak
and um uh you know that means you might
have to learn some different field that
you didn't know anything about you might
have to learn this you might have
learned that
um and sometimes you have to go
backwards and sort of say well i
i need to understand the basics of this
thing that i've never bothered to
understand before
and and then move forward from that i
mean i i guess that i find myself doing
that um
you know all my life i find myself
learning different kinds of things and
and constantly having to do that find
out that there are these different
building blocks that are needed
to learn a particular field and oh gosh
i don't know this thing well i probably
should have learned this thing 40 years
ago but i didn't
so okay so i can learn it now whatever
um and it's kind of fun
and uh uh you know i think that's i mean
the very concept
that you're going to do school and
that's going to be the complete learning
you do
and then you're going to go on and just
execute whatever you learnt
i think that's uh well i think you know
sometimes in some professions you might
be able to
get away with doing that but i think i
personally i have
found it very very nice to just keep
learning stuff
and the more you learn the more you know
and the more
the easier it gets to learn new things
and the more
the further you can get in my experience
because at least projects i do
i'm constantly having to pull things
from lots of different things that i
learnt at different times in my life
all right let's see
bunch of questions here so there's a
question from the
from tungsten squid interesting name
does a charged battery way more than a
discharged battery
oh boy how to think about that
um baba
do i know the answer to that question
well let me give you a way to think
about that
um let's not talk about batteries
because batteries are kind of
complicated
let's talk about capacitors okay so when
you make an electric circuit
the main thing you might have in your
electric circuit is let's say you're
making
something where you're lighting a bulb
you have a battery
that uh produces uh and then you have
wires
you have wires from the plus side of the
battery the minus side of the battery
to the two uh sort of ports on the on
the
on the light bulb you connect it up and
you know light bulb lights up well
what's happening there well what's
happening is
the battery is generating a voltage
voltage is kind of the force of pushing
electrons
which make up electricity pushing the
electrons through wires
and as you as those electrons are pushed
through the wires
they they get there's a certain flow of
electrons a certain current of electrons
that goes through the wires
and there's a certain resistance to the
electrons getting pushed through the
wires
that's the so-called resistance of uh
to electricity and in fact there's a
sort of a
basic formula in electricity that says
it's called ohm's law
that says voltage equals current times
resistance
and um so that means voltage is sort of
the force with which you have to push
the electrons with which you
like a battery for example is pushing
the electrons
current is the the rate of flow of the
electrons the number of electrons
per roughly area per time that's flowing
through the wire
and um the um
uh and then the um uh the resistance
is sort of how much you have to push to
get how many much
flow of electrons through the wire
and um so a very basic circuit
just has a voltage pushing a current of
electrons a resistance
to the to that pushing so there are
there are two other elements to sort of
the
basic so-called passive circuits things
called inductors and things called
capacitors
um i say a passive circuit because
there's circuits where you just get from
a battery
it's just like you're pushing and
something happens
an active circuit tends to be one where
you have things like switches
um in which uh things like sort of
electronically controlled switches
transistors are a sort of basic kind of
electronically controlled switch
in a transistor one has the the current
can go
through that it's like there's a in the
most common kind of transistor in
modern computers is a field effect
transistor which has a source
a gate and a drain so the source is a
place where you're sort of
putting the electrons in the gate is the
thing that's determining whether the
electrons can go through and the drain
is where the electrons come out
and so all of the kind of switching all
the logic that happens in computers it
all happens because
you can you have this gate that
depending on
essentially the voltage at this gate you
either do get the flow of electrons
through the transistor or not
that's an example of an active component
in a circuit
where you're actually actively doing
something to determine whether the
electrons are going to go through or not
but in a passive circuit there are
resistors inductors and capacitors
okay so uh
the okay so what are these things so
capacitor usually the
the different shapes but usually they're
little they're little cylindrical things
of different shapes
when you if you if you um if you open up
a piece of electronics
you'll find um that uh well you'll
mostly find that things are inside
integrated circuits just these little
these things where there might be
millions or billions of mostly
transistors uh
that are etched onto a piece of silicon
and an absolutely tiny and you can only
see them through a
high power microscope but they'll just
look like a little plastic
thing with a whole bunch of metal legs
on it
um that's a microprocessor or that's a
an integrated circuit
but they're also on on a circuit board
there will also be
uh other components um some that look
like little pieces of kind of wire like
things those are typically resistors
then there are also things that look
like our either little little um
like little boxes or sometimes like
cylindrical things that maybe stick up
those are capacitors um
they're also inductors they have various
different forms but but basically
inductors end up being loops of wire
okay so what are these things uh well
a capacitor is basically a a
temporary store of of
of of electrons um so
what will happen is current will flow
into a capacitor
the capacitor will just get more and
more and more electrons in it it will
just sort of fill up and fill up and
fill up
and then if you kind of let it
then it will let those electrons drain
out of the capacitor
again and make a um uh make
a current from those electrons draining
out so so a good example of this was
an old-fashioned flash before before
modern times
when people had um sometimes they still
do a big big
flash gun on a camera you would you
would sometimes hear it charging up it
might make a high-pitched noise it did
that
would charge up it would charge a
capacitor it has electric current
flowing into a capacitor
and that that means more and more
electrons are ending up in this
capacitor more and more and more
electrons end up in the capacitor
and eventually there's a lot of charge
in the capacitor
and then you press the camera you know
button and then kaboom all that charge
is released
all in one go and it makes uh it
uh makes the flash tube make a big flash
um so so kind of the idea of a capacitor
is
it's a storer of charge electrons
flow into the capacitor they sit there
because
once sort of closed off the the um uh
the
exit from the capacitor as soon as you
open that
as soon as you open the wire that goes
out from the capacitor let's say
as soon as you you know open a you might
have a an actual switch that you can
move there or something
or a button you press or something like
this as soon as you open that up
the the charge flows out of the
capacitor
uh by the way the the um
uh well an inductor is something a
little different an inductor
is is using um um
magnetic field i mean let's not talk
about inductors
um the the um let's talk about
capacitors
so capacitor is sort of a minimal store
of charge
like a battery now batteries have ways
to store charge that uses
electrochemistry that's a little
different
but it's the same basic idea so the
question we might ask
is is a charged capacitor does a charged
capacitor weigh more than an uncharged
capacitor
i think the answer is definitively yes
and the reason is it has more electrons
in it
it's got stuff in it that an uncharged
capacitor wouldn't have in it
and um i think that the um i'm trying to
think about how
one would know how this works but yes i
think that's right i think that the
amount of charge
so the um the capacity of a capacitor is
measured in this unit called farads
named after faraday um and there's
actually usually a
wide range from picofarads to
microfarads to whatever
of of capacity and i'm kind of thinking
that
um i think if i'm not getting this wrong
that um uh literally the the
amount of additional mass in a charged
capacitor will literally be the number
of electrons
that are in there that wouldn't
otherwise be in there and um
uh you know in a wire in a conducting
wire
what's happening is that there are
electrons that can actually move in the
conducting wire
in a metal so ordinarily in atoms
electrons there's a nucleus of an atom
there's electrons the electrons are sort
of
pinned they're sort of in quotes going
round not really quite going around but
they're hanging out around the nucleus
that's that's the way atoms normally are
in normal materials there's just a whole
array of atoms
um and uh um those some many materials
are just a whole array of atoms and each
atom has its as its electrons
hanging out around it now metals are
special
because metals have this feature that
essentially the electrons the atoms
with the electrons are are sort of close
enough together
that the the clouds of electrons around
the atoms kind of converge
and so you get what's called in in solid
state physics the
a conduction band which is basically
when the electrons
get sufficiently sort of uh they get to
a sufficient level of energy
they they get they get to the point
where the electrons can just
actually in a metal that they they're
just they're
pretty much well many of the electrons
are just able to sort of freely go
uh through the through the the solid
material
so they're not it's not like they're
locked to a single
nucleus uh to a single sort of a
and everything is a bunch of separated
atoms it's more like the electrons can
kind of roam
freely through this material and then
what happens is that voltage
is kind of putting it's putting an
electric field
um into the material that is providing
kind of a
a push it's like a hill with a gradient
whether the electrons are rolling down
this hill
um to uh uh and that's what generates an
electric current by the way
when it comes to a semiconductor so
there are there are
insulators which are things where the
electrons are pinned to atoms
and you can't make an electric current
go through those easily
something like um i don't know a a piece
of wood or something would be an
insulator
um or the air is an insulator um uh
those kinds of things then there are
metals which are conductors
where the electrons kind of roam freely
and you just have to push them a little
bit
with a voltage any any little tiny
voltage is enough
to push them even if it's a arbitrarily
small voltage it'll still
succeed in getting the electrons to move
through the material
then there's an intermediate case called
semiconductors
and semiconductors have the feature that
the electrons can only roam free if they
reach this conduction band
and there's a band gap and so the your
average electron doesn't reach that
point and you need a particular voltage
like six volts or something it's
different for silicon and different
materials
you need a particular voltage to push
those electrons into the conduction band
so that they can
kind of roam freely but um so that's uh
um but but um
i think the um in the case of uh uh
what if you know what when you move a
bunch of electrons into some place that
serves as a capacitor the capacitor will
weigh more
not much more but a bit more i think
um
okay let's see it's a question from
mahmoud here
um first question about is mathematics
invented or discovered that is a long
and very interesting question about
which i have lots to say
um but uh let's go on to the second part
of the question
how can one measure atomic number for
every element electron mass
and speed okay
so okay first of all chemical elements
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen
etc etc etc each of these different
chemical elements
these are essentially the different
kinds of atoms that exist in the world
and they're they they differ by
the number of protons in their nucleus
so hydrogen has one proton in its
nucleus helium has two
lithium has three beryllium has four and
so on all the way until you get
to uh uranium with 92 and then you get
up to i think we've got to about 120
now and i lose track a little bit
they're very unstable elements
and there's always new ones being
discovered um
but uh each one of those elements the
the number
is the number of protons in its nucleus
and um
so there's a question of uh kind of how
can you deduce how many protons there
are nucleus of each element
well people did that in the past
particularly in the 1800s
by studying the chemistry of each
element because the number of protons
when you have a neutral atom the protons
have plus one charge each
electrons have minus one charge each so
when you have a neutral atom
you have an equal number of protons and
electrons so that's kind of a
a um uh and by sort of studying how
how electrons get sort of uh in a
chemical compound get kind of borrowed
by one
uh nucleus and and uh rather than
another nucleus and so on
you can kind of piece together the whole
periodic table of what the atomic
numbers of the elements are now the
other quantity is atomic mass
the atomic mass is the total mass of the
protons neutrons electrons
in in in a um an element and
and um the number of neutrons is not
necessarily the same for all let's say
you have something like
helium there are two uh stable
isotopes of helium they both have two
protons
but one of them has one neutron the
other has two neutrons
it's helium-3 because it has a total of
three protons and neutrons in its
nucleus and helium four
which has a total of four protons and
neutrons in its nucleus
so there's a question of how do you
measure the atomic mass that is the
protons and neutrons
and the the most common way to do that
is with a thing called the mass
spectrometer
and essentially what happens in a mass
spectrometer is that you
are uh well in so the simplest case
you're you're sort of
breaking everything up until it's
individual atoms and then
you are basically uh accelerating those
individual atoms
by using an electric field and um
this is a little hard to explain but
basically what's happening is
you're making uh these individual atoms
you're making them kind of it would have
been easier to explain this
30 years ago this would have been a lot
easier to explain because 30 years ago
everybody had televisions that were
cathode ray tubes
they had televisions that worked by
having at the back of the television
there was a sort of hot wire that would
produce a stream of electrons
and the electrons would would just go
freely
through vacuum inside this this glass uh
um this glass uh uh
well usually called tube but but um of
the television this kind of glass
fishbowl type thing of the television
would go freely through this vacuum
from the from the kind of hot thing at
the back that's just streaming out
electrons
um and then the electrons will be pulled
towards the front
towards the the spin that you can see by
um a uh
by an electric field and usually there
was about thousands of volts
between the front and back of the tube
so to speak
and those thousands of volts were
pulling electrons in this case not
through a wire
but through a vacuum the electrons were
going through there and as the electrons
went through there
there will be these deflection plates
that would
be able to say okay this as as you
scanned
down the lines on the television screen
it's like at this place
we don't want an electron to land on the
screen we want it to be black there so
we deflect the electron away
when it gets to this point as it scans
we want to have the electron fall on the
screen
and then the screen would light up in
places electrons fell on it by having a
phosphor
that would have the property that that
um when an electron would fall on the
back of the phosphor
you would see a light on the front of
the phosphorus and that was a television
screen
okay so that's how that's how
televisions used to work but that's not
how televisions work today
television's work today using
solid-state electronics
and using either liquid crystal displays
or
or oleds organic light emitting diodes
um and uh the um
uh so so that piece of like everybody
knows how how that works doesn't really
isn't really good explanation anymore
but basically in a mass spectrometer
you're doing something that's a little
bit like what i was describing with the
television
except that instead of having a stream
of electrons you have a stream of
whatever atoms
you're trying to analyze and when you uh
are
kind of when when the you're
accelerating these atoms
and you're then deflecting them with a
certain force of deflection and
depending on their mass
they'll be deflected more or less that's
that's that's basically how mass
spectrometer works
and the result is that for any material
you can take any material
and you can just like like say well what
are the chemical elements what are the
how much of each chemical element is
there in that
in that piece of material and so you can
find out you know your random piece of
uh i don't know
um uh random
whatever it is piece of metal piece of
food you know
uh gemstone whatever it is you can just
figure out
how much of each chemical element is in
there and in fact it gets even more
subtle than that because you can figure
out how much of each isotope
things with different numbers of
neutrons uh for a given element
are in there and that gets really really
subtle because for example
um when uh if you have a deposit of i
don't know
um pick a material i don't know
tantalum niobium even gold whatever
in different minds the uh
when the earth was formed or when
geological processes formed
the rock in those mines it it
in in each different place there were
slightly different processes and so the
the fraction of different isotopes will
be slightly different
so you can kind of tell which mine
something came from
by using a mass spectrometer to find out
how much of each of these different
isotopes
actually occur
all right
there's a question about the
book about history of computation i'm
never very good at coming up with these
instant recommendations for books um
um
[Music]
there are a bunch of books about the
history i have a whole
several shelves of books about the
history of computing
um i always find it really interesting
to actually look at the original books
um from like the 1950s and so on
uh you know there were all these books
about giant electronic brains
which were kind of the metaphor for
computers back in those days
and it's kind of interesting to see you
know what's changed what hasn't changed
what people understood what people not
understood i would say the history of
computing
um a number of books about it but i
i would say not some history of
computing is is
it it's a little complicated because the
you know it's an interweaving of
intellectual developments
with commercial developments with
engineering developments
and they're all kind of woven together
and i'm not sure that
that it's um uh that there's a great
kind of um uh untangling of all those
different effects
because you know you can talk about the
abstract development of computing but
actually
you know a lot of the real steps that
were taken were taken you know when the
ibm 360 mainframe computer existed
when you know the sun workstation
existed when the unix operating system
was developed
all these kinds of things these are
these are the big steps were often
real projects done by real companies and
so on
um and uh uh that that it's the the
commercial history ends up getting quite
entangled
with the with the intellectual
development of the of these things
and that's sometimes hard for um uh to
to get handled well in kind of uh
historical narrative
i mean i would say that um there's a
there's a very nice computer history
museum in mountain view california
that has done a very nice job of of um
kind of telling the story
of um of uh sort of the the
of at least the technological side of
the computer
uh development of computers i mean for
me it's it's kind of a laid out
historically
for me it's kind of fun because it's
like um uh
you know you go through there and there
are computers from before i use
computers and then suddenly
there's this transition and all the
computers after that point are sort of
my personal friends so to speak it's
like yes i use one of those i had one of
those
et cetera et cetera et cetera it's kind
of kind of a fun thing of uh
for me at least it's like there's this
particular moment in time in basically
the
mid to late 1970s where sort of
everything after that time yep
been there seen that type thing and it's
sort of fun to
to to see that um
okay
um
okay several physics questions here
okay from camaro if it's true that sound
can be transmitted more easily in solids
compared to gases
why can we hear better through air
compared to through
walls or glass
okay interesting question all right the
basic answer
um is that
okay what is first of all what is sound
sound
is a series of compression and expansion
uh sort of a series of compressions and
expansions it's a wave
of comp where we go up you know as
compression down as expansion and so on
so when i talk what's happening is
there's air
that my vocal chords are moving
and that's uh that it's progressively
being compressed expanded compressed
expanded so
if i were to like if you play a um
a middle c on a piano then about 256
times a second
the air for the piano string will
vibrate and the air
around the piano string will be
progressively successively expanded
contracted expanded contracted
and so on and the feature of the
mechanics
of these things is that when there are
those series of expansions contractions
it it propagates it moves so so what was
a
an expan you know if i had my
loudspeaker cone
here or my piano string here that's
that's going back and forth
that's that's generating um air
that will move at the speed of sound
that that series of
of compression expansion
regions will move at the speed of sound
through air
okay so in a first approximation
with air with a gas if i play different
notes on a piano
88 notes on a piano they range that's
what five octaves or something
that's a factor of um uh 32 or something
in frequency that means that
at the low end you're dealing with oh
how low is it maybe a hundred
maybe i don't know how low it gets maybe
a few tens of vibrations per second
at the high end well the high end of of
like
um human there's a few thousand
vibrations per second and and we can
usually hear
if there are younger people listening to
this you can probably hear up to about
25 000
uh vibrations per second old fogies like
me
well it moves down twenty thousand
fifteen thousand uh vibrations per
second and so on
um that's you're hearing through these
little uh these little hair cells inside
the
the inner ear that are being uh as those
pieces of
compression expansion compression
expansion will move the hair cells back
and forth
and the hair cells uh are such that as
they move they generate an electric
they generate a little voltage and that
voltage causes
essentially an electrical effect to go
down the auditory nerve which is what
causes us to hear things
okay but any case so so the way that
sound
works it's this compression expansion
compression expansion
um you know many many times per second
okay
so one of the issues is different sounds
like if i make a very low
sound low frequency a few vibrations per
second if i make a high
frequency there's more vibrations per
second um
okay in air the the
the extent to which uh those different
sounds can go through air it's pretty
much the same
first approximation uh independent of
whether it's a low frequency or a high
frequency
sound the the sound wave will manage to
get through the air
okay the same is not true for things
like solids
in solids there are frequencies that are
well conducted
and there are frequencies that are not
well conducted so for example
in a solid uh okay so so what's roughly
happening
oh boy let's see yeah i mean basically
the issue is in
in um uh in a you know the question is
you make a sound eventually the sound
and the sound let's say you were able to
sort of direct your sound in one very
specific direction even so eventually
the these compression expansion
compression expansion
these things eventually as you move
these through the air eventually they'll
die out
eventually the um uh viscosity in the
air
um the um the fact that the air is not
doesn't
um if you if you try and move it with a
certain force
it doesn't quite respond there's a
certain amount of friction in a sense
um internal friction in the air that
causes it to not
uh not respond as much as you you push
it and doesn't quite respond as much as
you push it
well the same thing happens in solids
except it's more more significant there
and you know you you try and vibrate a
solid
and to what extent of the vibration is
going to go through the solid well it
depends
on the frequency of the vibrations the
extent to which they'll go through the
solid so
it tends to be the case that lower
frequencies go through solids pretty
well
so you're you're able to um have uh
um uh you're able to you know if you
if you bang on you know slowly on one
side of a
you know something solid thing you can
kind of
you know that the banging cup you know
can be heard on the other side but high
frequencies
um do not successfully they go through
solids they they get
sort of something essentially friction
damps them out very quickly and that's
why uh you know it works to have
kind of a um um
uh it it works to you know have a wall
that will prevent you hearing certain
kinds of things now you know
the absorption of sound is a complicated
issue and for example something like
acoustic tiles that you'll see on
ceilings
they uh there are different ways to
absorb sound
and um that the essentially the the um
that's one way another surprising way
that works surprisingly well as
is books and bookshelves you might say
why on earth would a room full of books
uh why would that be a really good why
would there be a bit good absorption of
sound in that room
so the things called helmholtz
resonators effectively what happens is
essentially the sound waves get you have
books on a bookshelf and there's some
space above the books
before you get to the next shelf and
essentially what's happening is the
sound is getting
in through that space and then it's
rattling around behind the books and
never gets out again
and that's um so it's it's kind of a an
almost mechanical reason for the
absorption of sound
so there are all kinds of different
things that lead to the absorption of
sound
in solids sound is just attenuated
by virtue of the fact that the solid has
some resistance to being
uh to being moved in a way that in the
air it's like you have an expansion wave
piece of expansion compression expansion
compression that's fine it goes through
the air but if you try and do that with
the solid the solid will resist and
we'll damp that out
so that's a sort of a rough story of why
um
even though when there are these these
some uh
when you do get vibrations going through
a solid the speed at which the
vibrations will go through
is higher than the speed at which
vibrations will go through a gas
like air but but many vibrations
particularly the higher frequency ones
will get
will get damped out by the by the
essentially the rigidity of the solid
uh so that's that's that's a um
a quick attempt i'm not sure if i've
forgotten any any big effects there but
i think that's a quick attempt to
explain that
um the question from i see here
why are mirrors made with glass would a
mirror
maybe the different material have
different reflective properties
okay so what is a mirror so what a
mirror has to do
is has to take something like light and
reflect it well
there are let's just see roughly what
there are mirrors for so
let's imagine that you had uh had
ripples
on water on the surface of water and
these ripples are sort of traveling as a
wave they're
wiggling the water and they they hit a
wall
they'll be a reflection of those ripples
from the wall
as the water hits the wall it will it
will have um
a certain there'll be water that's going
up and down at the wall and that water
that's going up and down at the wall
will lead to
water that goes up and down in the
direction and so
so as the as the the sort of the water
wave comes in here it'll get reflected
out out there so so waves in general
tend to get reflected from
things unless they're unless they're
completely absorbed
in the case of light uh the reflection
metals reflect light that's the basic
phenomenon and the wider metals reflect
light
okay so what's basically happening is
that as the light the light is an
electromagnetic wave it has
pieces of electricity and magnetism that
are wiggling in the case of visible
light
they're wiggling about a trillion times
a second um it's
uh there's sort of a change of electric
field magnetic field a trillion times a
second that's what a light wave is
when a light wave uh when when you shine
light on a metal
what's happening is that those
electrical magnetic fields
they will move the electrons around
inside the metal so as soon as that
light wave hits
the the metal it's like wiggling
electrons
in the in the surface level of the layer
of the metal
it's wiggling them really fast a
trillion times a second well one of the
features
of of wiggling electrons is when you
wiggle an electron it produces an
electromagnetic field
so the electromagnetic field has the
effect of wiggling the electron but the
wiggling of the electron
also produces an electromagnetic field
so electromagnetic field which is the
light wave comes in here
and it wiggles electrons in the material
and that wiggling of electrons produces
another light wave that's going out
and that's what leads to the reflection
so
in the case of um a a metal
um in uh metals will reflect specularly
in the sense that light wave comes in
and it's almost like a
like a you can almost think of it like
photons bouncing off
photons of light bouncing off the metal
and being bounced back
so if there's a certain angle that they
come in at they'll be bounced back out
at the same angle sort of on the
opposite side
that's so-called specular reflection
it's the same thing as what would happen
you know you have a billiard ball you
if you are any good at doing these kinds
of things you shoot it at the side of
the table
there's a sort of springy thing and it
will bounce off specularly it will with
an equal equal angle
so that's that's what happens in in um
that's that's the form of reflection
that you get
from uh from a metal and that's a
consequence of the fact light wave
wiggles electrons around the wiggling of
the electrons makes
makes another light wave and and insofar
as the the wiggling of those electrons
is is completely kind of without
friction
insofar as it like lightweight comes in
at wiggles electrons they just
you know produce another light wave then
you will get the specular reflection
now most materials that aren't sort of
perfect conductors perfect
metallic conductors and so on don't uh
have quite that same behavior
and they can have in general you can
have a very complicated pattern
of um okay so for example with a with a
specular reflector
you get like light comes in light sort
of bounces off like a billiard ball
the opposite extreme is a diffuse
reflector
where light comes in and the light comes
in and then the light that comes out
comes out at all angles sometimes called
the lambertian reflector
um and uh so a typical kind of
um uh surface that is um
uh yeah i should have explained
right it's a little complicated that the
okay okay let me explain another point
this idea that the light bounces
specularly off depends on the fact that
the surface of the
material is completely flat so
in other words the thing comes in and
bounces off if there was a little
ridge on the thing that was was
uh that was there the geometry would all
be different and so it would come in it
would hit the side of the
the photon effectively would hit the
side of the ridge and its version of
what
what counts as a specular reflection
will be different from what you would
imagine it would be
because it isn't it isn't flat to the
surface of your mirror
it's got little ridges on it and so on
so in order to have a sort of a perfect
mirror you have to have something that's
been sort of perfectly polished to be
completely
uh featureless and that's why when
people make i don't know
mirrors for i don't know like the hubble
space telescope um you know they're
very carefully making them perfectly
perfectly flat
and sometimes when people when people
one of the tricks for making
mirrors for telescopes is you take
mercury which is a liquid metal at room
temperature
and you literally spin it and the
surface that it makes actually is a
conveniently uh
a paraboloid which is the right shape to
make kind of a
the right thing for a telescope mirror
but that that will make you
the sort of the just that the surface of
the perfect surface of this liquid metal
will make you a good mirror because it's
it's sort of perfectly flat
so in addition to the fact you have to
have this metal which has the electrons
that can move freely
you also have to have it be perfectly
flat but in any case sort of the
opposite limit
is something where i don't know it's
like a uh something that is some
uh well very rough on the surface
or not a metal um it will be uh you'll
have this diffuse reflection
actually what really happens is light
comes in
and light goes out again in sort of a
cone that isn't precisely in the
specular direction
but it's kind of spread out like a
plastic for example typically
light will come in and the light which
comes out will spread out in a certain
cone
and in fact people there's both the
physics of this and there's also
this is in computer graphics the big
issue is shaders and computer graphics
where you're trying to work out what
will the simulated effect of light on
something be and it's a
very important thing in making realistic
looking computer graphics for movies and
things
is how that how the reflection of light
really works how the lighting really
works i mean
you might think you know that when you
make a a real movie with actual people
with big
lights around and shining them on you
know actors and things like that
you understand why in the credits
there's all kinds of credits to people
who do lighting and
and the electrical stuff for lighting
and so on and so on and so on
but then when you see an animated movie
there's often in the credits also
a lot of stuff about lighting and so on
you say how could that possibly be i
mean who's moving a light around well
the answer is
it's a complicated art to get things to
look right
um with respect to having uh light
fall on simulated things in a in
computer graphics
and over the course of time people
figured out uh
different kinds of tricks for making
things at least look right
in terms of how light is reflected so
for example back um well there's things
uh
they have names fong shading garage
shading
these are all tricks for kind of making
things that look like certain kinds of
materials they'll use some
some instead of having things precisely
specularly reflect there'll be a sort of
power law
of you know oh the 10th power is good
for plastic and things like this
different
different materials have these different
uh sort of scattering characteristics of
how the light comes out
how light even when it shines in in one
beam at a particular angle
how it will come out and then there are
much more complicated things like
skin and hair those are really
complicated to figure out because
the way that they reflect light depends
on the fact that
there are features of skin for example
in the case of skin
one of the complicated things is that
light is not quite all reflected from
the surface of the skin
the light penetrates a few layers into
the skin
and some of it is reflected deeper and
so on so that gets complicated in case
of hair
it's complicated because every strand of
hair is kind of
separately is well and the sizes of hair
are not so far off from the wavelength
of light and so you get all kinds of
effects from that and so on
if you're a if you're something like a
um
a chameleon you're really using these
effects of um
wavelength of light being similar to the
um uh the though in that case it's the
it's cells in the in the skin of the
chameleon that allows it to change color
and so on
but any case so so it's a it's a
complicated issue how you get
um um how you deal with these sort of
different ways that light is
is reflected from different kinds of
materials um and very important for
making things look realistic and so on
it's kind of like
you know when we when we perceive things
color is one important
aspect of what we perceive but we also
perceive textures of things
we understand pretty well how eyes see
color in terms of red green and blue
we understand much less well her eyes
sees texture
there's probably some some limited set
of sort of feature detectors for texture
just like there are three different
color detectors in our eyes they're
probably some number of texture
detectors
we don't completely understand how that
works it's probably partly in the retina
uh the actual sort of light sensing part
of our eye
and partly in the first levels of visual
processing in our brains
um that that works out um but that's
kind of a uh
so that's a that's a rough story and i
think the um
um the question about mirrors
um yeah and depending on what material
the mirror is made from there are
all kinds of complicated things you can
do with mirrors and there are mirrors
that
change um the polarization of light uh
when i talked about these
electromagnetic fields and sort of the
wiggling of the electron
and magnetic fields there are different
directions in which that wiggling can
happen
and those correspond to the polarization
of the light
and that can also be affected by how
it's reflected and so on there's a
a long and interesting story about that
for people and
things called stokes parameters which
are um
uh the the kind of the fancy you know
electromagnetic theory version
of how you characterize how a light wave
gets reflected from
from something and so on lots of
interesting physics there
all right let's see question here which
was
a uh from eudacio uh what was my first
computer
well the first computer i saw was from a
distance
in probably 1969 when i was kind of like
nine years old
and it was a mainframe computer that was
only
you know as a giant computer the size of
a room that
was only sort of operated by people in
kind of white coats and so on
um first computer that i
put my own fingers on and programmed
was a computer called elliott 903c
and it was a computer it's about the
size of a desk
it was a computer that had um um it was
about
um a thousand times slower
ten thousand times slower than today's
computers it had about
uh it had eight thousand words of memory
eight thousand words of 18 bit memory so
that's about
24 kilobytes of memory so very small
amount of memory
ferrite core memory so every individual
bit of memory
was a little tiny magnet effectively um
that was all sort of threaded together
and um you programmed it with with paper
tape um
and uh a little this
paper with with holes punched out of it
um and that was
programmed as a language in its assembly
language and it's um
um uh essentially it's machine code
um and that was that was the first
computer i used
um then um after that i it's sort of a
trade-off in those days because that was
a computer
that was in yes it was in a sort of well
there wasn't a lot of air conditioning
it was a sort of air-conditioned room
sort of out on its own but um uh you
know the question of when there was a
computer that could be out in the wild
not in a very special environment that
was a different thing
and the computers often computers would
be computers that when used
at a distance um most often well in
the big computers it was usually with
cards where you would type up your cards
on a card punch
you'd make a big stack of cards be
careful not to drop them because they
were really a mess to reorder if you
dropped them
you put them in a you know a pigeon hole
wooden pigeon hole usually
somebody would take them out run them
through the computer
and put back a printout of the results
that you got um
that was kind of a common way to use big
computers
then another thing that started to exist
back
oh when i was this must have been 1976
1975 1976. um
yeah i mean uh the sequence of computers
that were my personal friends so to
speak
but um another thing was starting to
exist was was
things called vdus visual display units
otherwise known as
things which actually had visual display
like televisions
that allowed you to actually see
characters you were typing in rather
than just
you type it in cards you give it to
somebody the results come back
but so um uh
by the time there were vdus um visual
terminals um they're started to be so i
i then started using computers
uh well when i was like 16 years old i
worked at this government lab in england
and they had um a whole fancy setup
for doing um uh for having
terminals where you could get sort of
somewhat real-time access to a computer
you didn't tend to run your programs
you know it wasn't like you typed to
program in and it ran right there
you would you would set up your program
and you sort of tell it
submit the job and then it would run the
program and then
15 minutes later an hour later or
something you get the results back
um at the same time actually i also
started using i used a desk
calculator which was an electronic thing
i think made by hp
that was more of a like a a very big
version of a calculator
um and uh where you could write programs
and it had little magnetic cards that
you could write programs on
and had a pen plotter that allowed you
to make essentially graphics by
literally having a pen
that would be controlled to move on a
piece of paper um
and uh i made a bunch of bunch of things
with that
then the first computer what was the
first computer i owned
um i think the first computer that i
owned was i'm trying to think about this
um
well i yeah mostly i used computers that
i sort of had uh that
were i didn't personally own um
but uh were just at labs
universities whatever sometimes there
were computers that
you know i controlled in some way or
another but i didn't personally own them
they weren't um
um i did um uh
i started using well i used
oh gosh lots of kinds of computers but i
i i i often use computers remotely i
mean i used computers through the
arpanet which was a predecessor of the
internet back in 1976
even from england i was using computers
in the us that way
um but uh i think
after a while i started using um
uh probably by 1978 i i used to use
computers and i used to have a
terminal um that was usually
you know 80 characters across 24 lines
down
um that had to be that would just be
sending
commands to a computer um but uh
the um you could do that through a phone
line
and i would take a terminal take it home
connect it to a phone line through one
of these acoustic couplers where you're
actually using the sound on the phone
line to send data
and the the amazing thing was the phone
system at least in the us or in
california or where i was that time
was sort of good enough that you could
literally leave the thing connected for
months at a time
and it would never get any data errors
and you could just you know you come
back and you start typing on this
terminal
and it's all connected and you're
connected to your computer and you can
do things anyway the first computer i
think i owned
personally was probably an osborne one
which was a which was an early portable
computer
the size of a small suitcase um and it
had
floppy disks and things and i actually
have to say i didn't use it very much
it was it was kind of annoying to use
relative to the the sort of big
computers that i
that i had access to um and uh
uh yeah so i could go through i could go
through the whole series of
of computers in my life so to speak but
i think it probably gets a little bit um
uh long in the tooth after a while so i
should probably
stop stop there all right
let's see a question from sylvester
about morphic resonance i
don't have no idea what that is um
question from pomenides
how long have i known don knuth don
knuth is a
person uh sort of uh computer science
kind of one of the kind of uh
distinguished old-school computer
scientists
how long have i known dawn probably
since the late 1970s i think um
don has written this um he's done many
things but he's written this
well-known book collection of books
about the art of computer programming
and uh i kind of um um
uh it's kind of one of those life
planning kinds of things he started
writing an eight volume series of books
back in about 1968 and he reached volume
three fairly quickly
and he's been working on volume four for
years since then and i
i'm afraid he's he's quite old at this
point and i i
kind of i'm hoping he's going to get it
all done but but you know
volume 4 has expanded so that i think
volume
4 is now in many many many many many sub
volumes
and i think the problem is that back in
1968 when he started all this stuff
the field of computer science and what
there was to say about different
computer algorithms a really very small
field
now it's two things have happened first
it's a much larger field and secondly i
think don
has gotten more and more into the
details of more and more things and has
just discovered more and more stuff
and it's like the the the project is is
like
expanding you know it's not clear that
the project is a convergent project i
think it may expand faster
than the years go by so to speak um
but i think the um uh it's some
it's something where um
as somebody myself who's been involved
in doing large projects
this is this is one of the kind of
things that is like
a uh be careful what you set up because
you know you set up a sort of table of
contents you say i'm going to execute
this table of contents
how long is it going to take like i
wrote this big book called the new kind
of science i started it in 1991
i wrote down the table of contents and i
thought okay
i'm going to fill out this table of
contents turns out these sections which
i thought oh i'm not going to have much
to say about that
turns out i had lots and lots and lots
to say about it
so that table of contents 12 chapters
ended up taking 10 years um and uh you
know i discovered lots of things that i
pretty pleased with and uh you know i
think that book
has been and continues to be a very sort
of successful thing
but um it's still it's like you set up
the table of contents
you start writing it and like if you are
fixed on your table of contents
then um uh then it may take a while to
finish it if it's an ambitious table of
contents kind of like
when we do big software releases there's
always a continual
discussion in our company is there a
release where we say there's this
particular set of features that have to
go into this release
or is this a release that must come out
on this particular date
and it's always a trade-off and it's
always sort of a compromise between
those kinds of things
but don has set up for himself this uh
this table of contents which um
i i just hope he manages to to work his
way through because it's it's
some uh the numbers the analytics don't
look so fantastic but um
uh but but um it's it's a it's a
wonderful thing to have a
have a project like that that has such
such ambitious goals
it's a question from mustachio
noting that i went to oxford and caltech
would i recommend these schools well
first you have to realize that i went
there a long time ago
and i was on the faculty at caltech for
a while and
um uh you know i've i've i
i went to these schools uh
40 years ago more than 40 years ago 44
years ago in the case of oxford
um so you know much has no doubt changed
some has
stayed the same i think you know the
thing to understand about about
colleges schools universities whatever
um
is you know people think oh there's this
thing like the us news and world report
ranking
it's like they're the top n colleges
okay
i should try to go to the top college
that would be the best college to go to
well it's not necessarily true because
colleges
are not all the same i mean it's like
saying
you know i could read a book any book
well books are different
so are colleges and you know different
colleges have different personalities
different things they're strong
about different kinds of students who go
there um different kinds of experiences
they lead to
and i think people are you know often
too focused on there's a there's a
ranking and i got to go to the
you know the top one well you know top
for one person may not be top for
another person i think there are
different
different categories of of colleges and
different categories of experiences that
people get and different things like
if you're going to be the top person at
this not
so you know college that doesn't have
quite such amazing test scores of
students
but you're going to be a top student
that may be a better experience than
being kind of a
oh i'm really struggling at this place
where everybody has top test scores
now you know and i think the whole world
of colleges have been
bizarrely at least in the u.s less so in
in places like england i think
although there it's happening as well
have been so dominated by you know who's
going to get the perfect test score the
perfect resume the perfect whatever
and i don't even know you know it is a
it is a bizarre
kind of search for perfection in some
definition of perfection
i don't really know what that translates
into i mean as a person who sees
often the output of colleges i i i would
say that
the people who like you know there's a
certain you know you take the most elite
colleges and in many cases
in order to sort of uh go there
sort of lots of ducks have to line up
you have to you know perfect test scores
perfect uh
uh you know activities perfect this
perfect that
um okay the kinds of people who get
perfect test scores
if you uh want to be the most creative
you know discover
the most interesting thing may not
correspond to the person who gets the
best test scores
the person who's going to have the um uh
you know the most tenacity
at getting a project done the person
who's going to have the most creativity
the person who's been
going to be the most personable in
dealing with other people not
necessarily much at all to do with test
scores
um but yet that ends up being the filter
that's used in many cases
in uh you know in determining oh this
eliteness of college versus that
i mean it's also worth realizing that a
lot of what people you know
the the i think the the best reason to
go to college
probably is because you actually want to
learn stuff
um and uh maybe you want to learn stuff
that you didn't already know you wanted
to learn and so on that's but that turns
out to be a pretty small fraction
of people who go to college now another
fraction of people they want to go into
particular professions where you need to
know certain kinds of things you're
going to be a doctor
you need to know certain kinds of things
and that's a process that's
a ladder that gets client going through
college and so on
i mean they're also uh people who like
go to college as sort of a social
experience
and um uh both as a sort of a stage of
life experience which
people i think which you know it's funny
at different times in history people
have had different sort of
that stage of life experiences you know
they
have to join the army they have to do
this they have to do that but anyway
they leave the nest they go off and do
something they launch their lives type
thing and that's the thing
that's sort of a reason to be in college
and then there's another thing which is
you're going to meet all kinds of people
who
form a kind of social network that um
uh will be relevant interesting
enriching to you
going forward and that's another
perfectly good reason to go to college
it's a little bit weird it's like
joining a you know a club of some kind
and it's kind of a weird thing because
it's like you are
you're being selected supposedly for
sort of academic reasons to join this
club that you really are joining
for reasons that have nothing to do with
academics um and that's a bit of a
strange thing
and um you know i noticed that uh you
know we
have um summer camp for high school
students summer school
we put on every year and you know we we
get all kinds of very interesting
applicants we get very interesting
people coming to our summer school and
summer camp
those people represent for each other an
interesting network we didn't pick them
to be a network so to speak
but we picked them for certain you know
for
because they had some characteristics
and then it turns out people like
meeting other people who have sort of
similar characteristics to their own
and i noticed the same thing at our
company you know we've got a very
interesting group of people and uh it's
always nice to see that people
not everybody gets on with everybody but
it seems like an awful lot of uh
uh great sort of
sort of relationships friendships start
up through just
being people who were sort of selected
for a different reason
to have certain similarities end up
being people that um
it's um uh that you you want to hang out
with
so to speak and and you know in the end
you know i went to
uh you know when i was in in um in
england i i went to sort of a top
high school called eaton then i went to
oxford and these are sort of top
schools in this sort of english thing
and there's this whole notion of the old
boy
club so to speak uh hopefully now it's
the old boys and girls club but i'm not
sure
um it always used to be called the old
boys kind of network so to speak
of people um uh who uh sort of know each
other from those things and
and i you know i've lived in the us now
for 40 something years so
i'm kind of a little bit out of that
that world but
it is always amusing to me a little bit
scary to me at my age that
that um uh you know the people that i
knew in school
are the people who who are running the
country and things like this at this
point it's kind of like um
uh and i mean it's amusing it's a little
bit a little bit
terrifying at some level that these
people that i last really knew when i
was like
13 years old and now and this actually
some of them are even
have done and are now retired from uh
which is even worse
um from you know being you know this the
secretary of the treasury or whatever it
is in
in um um and uh sort of sort of
interesting how that works out and i
think that
there's a certain sense in which oh you
meet these people then you'll get to
know them it's actually different in
different countries you know the us is a
big country
um although sadly a bit stratified so
it it operates in some ways as a smaller
country but but it's still it's very big
there are other countries that are
smaller where sort of everybody knows
everybody and a certain
certain sort of of the people who are uh
you know involved in universities and
government and this and that and the
other
uh england is sort of an intermediate
case of medium size i would say
um but you know that's another sort of
dynamic of universities is some
concentrator
for certain kinds of people for better
better or worse
okay let's see i'm gonna have to wrap
soon
um
let's see
bye bye bye lots of interesting
questions
oh boy um
okay there's a question from luis here
golf balls have dimples that allow them
to move faster
why do cars and planes not have dimples
oh complicated question well basically
if you want something to move fast you
want it to kind of slide through the air
without making the air do uh
do too many kind of get kind of get into
too much
sort of complicated messy motion you'd
really like it to be
nice and streamlined so the edges sort
of slides past you
and depending on exactly how fast the
air is going and how big you are
you need kind of different shapes so for
example a plane
that goes below the speed of sound needs
a nose that has a certain form a plane
that goes around the speed of sound has
a pointy nose
a plane that goes actually plane below
speed of sound has roughly a parabolic
uh nose uh around the speed of sound
it's a pointy nose like the concord had
a way above the speed of sound it's a
hyperbolic shape like the space shuttle
has a very snub looking
nose um that uh uh didn't didn't
didn't have that same form um and um
uh the um
um that's my reminder that i need to go
soon
um the uh in any case the the the thing
that
um uh what happens in
it matters a lot the the layer of air
right
away from the thing that's moving past
it it matters a lot what that
what what the surface looks like so for
example it can matter
on a plane for example whether its wings
are dirty or not
you know washing its wings can make it
can make it have less drag
less that the air tends to sort of stick
on the wings less as the as the plane
goes through the air
and there are lots of details like the
on a plane on the wings of a plane
you'll see that you might think oh the
plane's wings should be perfectly smooth
so it will be as streamlined as possible
but actually they're not so if you look
on the wings of a typical plane they'll
often have a little
little sort of fence of little little
things that stick up
um and uh you'd say why on earth would
it have something like this they're
usually about
a little bit less than an inch tall um
those have to do with
affecting the detailed flow of air in
the so-called boundary layer
near the wings the the air away from the
wings is
like stationary and the air right at the
wing is moving
is being pulled along by the plane as
the plane flies through the air
um the the details of sort of the
transition between
air is being pulled along with the plane
and air is stationary is rather subtle
and those little fences are kind of a
little bit like the dimples on a golf
ball
they break up the boundary layer and
cause the plane to be able to have less
drag as it moves through the air
and there are lots of other details like
that but that's roughly the rough story
is yes there are actually things like
that
and there are lots of tricks for for
making um
uh for breaking up boundary layers and
things like that i think
cars i think cars sometimes have those
kinds of things as well
um same same kind of phenomenon it's
it's a slightly i could i could expound
about this at great length
um about the physics of fluids but let
me not do that right now
um the question here
about the question about claude
shannon um who i unfortunately never met
uh i know many people who knew him but i
never personally met him
uh a question from blue banana
um banana um
okay you say that in philosophy everyone
can think about fundamental questions
why is that
why is that the case in philosophy but
not in physics or mathematics
um why does philosophy not have a
similar rigid corpus of theory
as the hard sciences do that's a really
interesting question i think the main
point is
okay as a practical matter in today's
world
there's a formal structure of knowledge
in
in science and mathematics that is sort
of built layer upon layer
and the things we can do now are things
where
you can build sort of on top of that
platform in philosophy
i would say that there's less of such a
platform that's been built in fact
what's ended up happening in philosophy
is whenever it starts building one of
those platforms the
area of investigation in which the
platform is built
stops being called philosophy and starts
being called natural philosophy or
physics
or something instead so in a sense
philosophy is is left with the things
for which there hasn't been
this same kind of layered uh you know
platform
built that allows one to then then do
things
so i think as a practical matter what
ends up happening is
to really you know say something new in
some area of physics let's say you're
probably going to have to know a fair
amount of that
those layers that have been built so far
it's
less true in mathematics because of
computer experiments
where you can sort of parachute into
some parts of the sort of mathematical
universe
by doing a computer experiment without
sort of visiting all the all the
intermediate state
stages but um in um uh but generally you
know if you want to make a contribution
to sort of mathematics as it's written
up in standard mathematics journals and
so on
you kind of need to know all those
layers this platform that's been built
over the course last of the course of
the last many centuries
in mathematics in philosophy one of the
things that is sort of perhaps
um well you know i always used to make
fun of this
my mother happened to be a philosophy
professor in oxford actually
um and uh so i always used to say if
there's one thing i'll never do when i'm
grown up it's philosophy and of course
needless to say
after decades go by here i am talking
about philosophy and
and uh writing about philosophy kinds of
things and and so on but
uh that's that's what happens eventually
eventually the um
uh uh you know you you realize that the
things
your parents did hopefully you realize
it more quickly
um weren't as different from what you're
interested in as you thought
they were but anyway one of the things i
always used to make fun of about
philosophy
is it's like okay we're in 1960
something or other
and how come you're still arguing about
the same questions that aristotle was
talking about
you know in in the third century bc or
whatever haven't you made progress in
the last 2000 years
you know and and um uh and so i think
that's
that's sort of an interesting thing
about philosophy is that in a sense the
questions
and even some of the answers are sort of
the same and you can debate them
and it's partly a feature of sort of the
human condition the structure of
thinking it hasn't really changed
but now as i say every so often there's
a sort of power
assist that happens in philosophy
whether it's in logic
and the formalization of logic and
mathematical logic building out that
tower
building out the tower that became
physics building out other kinds of
towers
that that do have this sort of rigid
formal structure
and which will to some extent lock them
out of
being things that people that sort of
anybody can have a a
you know a modern opinion about so to
speak but i think that's not
that's not the case with with many areas
of philosophy
and um i think that the question of
whether you could imagine making a sort
of
a rigid framework a sort of formal
framework for different areas of
philosophy it's a very interesting
question
i think that um it's a question not
unrelated to things that i've thought
about
um you know for example ethics is one
area where
in a sense there is a codification of
ethics that
is needed for ai and things like that
because
you know ethics as thought about by
humans oh it's a complicated process you
ask people there are laws there are
these kinds of things that it's a it's a
slow thinking type process
but you know the self-driving car that
has to make an ethical decision about
what to do
it's going to make that decision in 50
milliseconds and
something has got to be making that
decision ethically so to speak
and that's got to be sort of formulated
in some formal way
so that in 50 milliseconds it can decide
what to do and so i think that sort of
forces
what has been a let's debate it kind of
thing into a let's write code that does
it kind of thing
and that sort of forces a different
thinking a more formal kind of thinking
about questions for example in ethics i
mean the same has
happened in questions in epistemology
ontology these kinds of areas
um some of these questions in fact some
of the things i've done
both in in thinking about science in
general and specifically in our physics
project
kind of turn what have been kind of
philos
philosophical debate questions into
questions which are really questions
that
where we can just say here's this thing
you can do a computer experiment you can
see this happening
you can reason about it you can formally
reason about it and and you can make
progress
and and perhaps that will cause certain
questions of philosophy
to to change their character and become
more formal and become less accessible
i mean i think some of these things one
of things i always find interesting
is these things which sort of start us
philosophy and maybe i heard about when
i was a kid
as pieces of philosophy about you know
oh references to things you know
when is this thing referring to
something that actually exists you know
when you talk about the king of france
and whether the king of france
is is has this or that attribute it's
you know what does that mean if there
isn't a king of france what kind of a
statement is that
well it's like who cares that's just
something for the philosophers to debate
i don't care well until i do because i
really care
because when we build our computational
knowledge system in wolfram alpha we
have exactly questions
about what does it mean when the thing
you reference doesn't exist
and how do we how do we deal with
reasoning about
things where the thing that you
reference doesn't exist and what can we
say about it
and when can we make an aggregate
statement about things where some things
exist and some things don't and so on
and so what started as philosophy ends
up as code so to speak
and ends up as something for which you
have to make a formal structure i think
that over the course of time
the kind of computational paradigm is
going to encroach further and further
on what traditionally has been
philosophy and we're going to end up
with a more sort of computational
philosophy
that that indeed will be a more formal
system and where certain kinds of things
that have been matters of kind of every
everyday debate end up being things
where there is a layer of formalism that
one has to kind of
that if one wants to reach sort of the
frontiers of what can be talked about
one has to
one has to go through
all right well i think um i'd better
wrap up here
um and um uh
thanks for coming i see the questions i
didn't get to today which i'd love to
to answer and i will try and go on again
um
next week so until then bye for now